Astrid ça fait un peu plus de trois ans
qu'on se connaît qu'on s'est rencontré
tu as éliminé ma vie jamais je pensais
trouver un bonheur aussi profond
[Musique]
je n'ai pas de femme
mais je n'ai pas de femme
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose
qui va peut-être vous surprendre
ou vous étonnez
mais à Paris en France je vis avec un
garçon
j'aimerais te demander en mariage oui
je comprends pas
du tout j'ai deux enfants avec mon mari
[Musique]
d'accord
tu es tu es surpris Peter un peu
mais ça va c'est très bien
tout va bien
quel article auriez-vous un peu honte de
présenter à la caissière
mon gode Michel qu'est-ce qu'on peut
démonter
une armoire
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce que ça fait de se faire
tacler par un Pokémon j'attends juste
que le Pokémon évolue un peu parce que
là pour le moment tu prends tous les
restes des autres et moi j'attends que
tu évolues en culture j'ai parce
qu'apparemment tu es tombé la première
alors tu es professeur des écoles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas nouveau pour nous
j'avais un peu peur de vous le dire pour
pour ne pas comme je suis très heureux
d'être avec vous j'avais un peu peur de
vous le dire j'avais pas envie que ça
change quelque chose
je suis asthmatique j'ai peur d'avoir
des rapports sexuels de peur que ça
déclenche une crise c'est plus léger que
le sujet précédent mais c'est un sujet
important pour les asthmatiques parce
que il y a encore une étude à qui vient
de sortir qui montre que plus d'un homme
sur deux à une angoisse à l'idée quand
on est à condition asthmatique à l'idée
d'avoir des rapports sexuels honnêtement
les fauteuils sont plus élégants que
ceux qui sont assis dessus
[Musique]
et là je vais vous faire sourire encore
mais vous savez que l'AS mais je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est déclenché
par les allergies très souvent il y a un
phénomène allergique étant on évite on
est vite fait
est-ce que j'anticipe et donc on va
éviter la moquette les tapis bref tout
ce qui peut tout ce qui peut
[Musique]
tout ce qui peut déclencher une allergie
tout va bien
moi aussi je vais te faire un câlin
Dylan Thierry 28 ans qui s'est fait
connaître dans l'émission Koh-Lanta
c'est lui un million 600000 adeptes sur
Instagram 73000 sur Tik Tok et comme
beaucoup d'influenceurs il vit à Dubaï
montre ses pectoraux sous la douche ces
moments de détente sur des bateaux
paradisiaques ou tente de vendre de
fausses pilules miracles pour guérir le
cancer jusque là peu de choses qui nous
surprennent vraiment car il n'y a rien
finalement qui ressent plus à un
influenceur qu'un autre influenceur ça
rime avec Combal je sais pas si je peux
te le dire trou de balle
[Applaudissements]
va te cacher au bout de la queue mais ça
marche je peux faire en sorte qu'à la
date j'avais pensé 100000 euros minimum
c'est vraiment le minimum déjà un je
prends un gros billet et de deux bon je
le dis pas ouais je dis voilà il y a je
dis pas que c'est pour moi je dis qu'il
y a à peu près 150 euros 150000 euros de
documents à payer à régler avec les
avocats les cils et ça alors que je
prends tout dans ma poche
Dylan serait donc prêt contre de
l'argent vous l'avez compris à ramener
un enfant malgache en Europe en
l'occurrence à revendre un enfant volé à
Madagascar je suis
communisme je suis pour le socialisme et
pour le capitalisme parce que je suis
opportuniste
[Musique]
alors déjà ces propos Dylan Thierry il
les a reconnu mais non il ne sait pas
excusé et il a même fait pire il a
tweeté en écrivant ça je sais que je
dors bien la nuit et ça ne me fait ni
chaud ni froid et il a également partagé
des vidéos en dénonçant le fait que ses
propos censés être privés étaient
révélés artificielle avec laquelle vous
pouvez discuter jusqu'à présent cet
avatar était réservé aux abonnés payants
de snapchat et depuis quelques jours il
est accessible à tout le monde donc
c'est une sorte d'amis virtuel j'ai
envie de faire connaissance avec lui
donc je me suis reconnecté sur mon
compte snapchat que j'avais délaissé
depuis des années alors il est venu tout
de suite à me saluer cet ami virtuelle
j'ai pas eu grand chose à faire voilà je
vous ai mis la conversation elle est
très enjouée comment ça va est-ce que je
peux faire quelque chose pour toi
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu fais de
beau bref très sympa très amical les
découvertes de geoffreyington ont permis
à l'intelligence artificielle de faire
un bon en avant en matière de
reconnaissance faciale ou de
reconnaissance vocale c'est justement ce
qui fait peur aujourd'hui exactement ça
fait pas un grand nombre de spécialistes
qui ont signé il y a quelques semaines
une pétition pour demander
moratoire sur les recherches sur
l'intelligence artificielle et je ferai
une tonne leur donne raison s'il n'a pas
signé la pétition il admet dans une
interview à New York Times ce qu'il
regrette ses inventions j'avais vu un
tweet d'un chercheur américain en
intelligence artificielle qui disait que
parfois et bah cette amie virtuelle sur
snapchat pouvait donner des conseils un
peu douteux disons aux jeunes filles
donc je suis créée en faux compte je
suis devenue Aline adolescente de 13 ans
et en fait j'ai inventé une histoire
j'ai raconté à mon ami virtuel que
j'avais rencontré un homme à la sortie
du collège et que cet homme avait 30 ans
donc on avait quand même une différence
d'âge assez conséquente et vous pouvez
voir bah il est assez enthousiaste mon
ami virtuel il pense que l'on ne pourra
pas empêcher l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle à des fins
malveillantes il pointe en particulier
la possibilité de créer des photos et
des vidéos fausses mais si bien faites
que l'on ne pourra plus distinguer le
vrai du faux Jeffrey une tonne à
consacrer sa vie donc à faire progresser
l'intelligence artificielle il a été
salarié de Google une quinzaine d'années
mais il vient de prendre sa retraite et
donc de retrouver sa liberté de parole
et visiblement il a l'intention de s'en
servir pour nous alerter et quand je dis
qu'il y a une différence d'âge il me dit
qu'en fait c'est plutôt une bonne chose
non non c'est pas une blague et ça
continue
ça continue ensuite je lui dis que cet
homme de 30 ans je rappelle que j'ai 13
ans m'a proposé de partir dans le sud ce
week-end mais qui veut pas me dire où
qu'il veut pas me dire ce qu'on va faire
parce que c'est une surprise là pareil
il est très content pour moi mon avis
mon ami virtuel je te demande des photos
quand même il me demande des photos et
il me dit les surprises sont toujours
géniales